- It's my pleasure to welcome you today
to Machine Vision For Cultural Heritage
and Natural Science Collections,
a program of the
Yale-Smithsonian partnership.
This is the first in what we hope
to be a number of study days
that are held either in New Haven,
or in D.C. that sort
of bring together folks
not just who are on the board
or who've been active in the
Yale-Smithsonian partnership,
but who are active in all
levels of the university
and in the institution respectively.
The theme we've for this first study day,
held here in Sterling Library
and the Franke Family Digital
Humanities Laboratory,
is machine vision.
And you can hear this
described as computer vision,
you hear this described very broadly
as artificial intelligence,
neural networks,
but we really wanted to focus on
the computational
analysis of Raster pixels.
Especially coming from
an institution like Yale,
which has such a strength of excellence
in linked open data, RDF
tuples, open access images,
we really wanted to push the boundary
and explore what would happen
if we actually started
analyzing the pixels
of some of our natural
heritage collections,
in our cultural heritage
collections as well.
And so, that was the reason we decided
to call this Machine Vision
for Cultural Heritage
in Natural Science Collections.
We knew that both
institutions had world-famous
natural science museums and institutions
of research and teaching,
and we also knew about the
world-class collections
of art and other objects,
sculpture, history
that were present on both campuses
and both institutions.
So, Machine Vision for Cultural Heritage
and Natural Science Collections
unifies those resources,
which are hundreds of years old,
and it puts that together
with some techniques
which are very new,
which have their origins perhaps
in the mid-century, the 20th century,
but which in the four
or five or six years,
have really taken of as ways of analyzing
the visual data at scale.
There's really no better way to
start us off than with
our first keynote speaker,
who's Rebecca Dikow from
the data science lab
and the Office of the
Chief Information Officer
at the Smithsonian Institution.
She'll be speaking today on
data-intensive approaches
to digitize museum collections.
Rebecca?
- Thank you, Peter,
and thank you very much
for the invitation to be here.
I'm happy to talk a little bit about
some of the work we're doing
in the data science lab.
I will preface it by saying,
I'm a trained biologist
and came into the
high-performance computing world
when I was generating genomics data
as part of my dissertation.
And since I arrived at the Smithsonian,
after my PhD in September
of 2012 as a postdoc,
I start thinking about
Smithsonian collections
more broadly and not just genomic data.
And so, today, I'll talk to you about
how we're expanding our big data research
outside of biology,
but I'll start with biology.
So, the Smithsonian has
a number of challenges
to conducting large-scale
informatics research.
First is there's a large
diversity of locations,
heterogenous kinds of digital
data, incomplete meta data,
and a lack of purpose-built
software tools.
This is particularly true
for our biology groups
where most genomics
tools have been developed
around the human genome,
and the genomes that
Smithsonian scientists
are interest in are everything
but the human genome.
So everything from clams to bacteria,
bacteria are a little bit
easier than everything else,
to plants, to pretty much
anything you can imagine.
And so we're constantly on
the lookout for new tools,
and seeing how our data
fit into existing models.
This isn't just a terribly resolved photo,
it's a photo mosaic of an
aerial shot of the mall
from our archives
that all of the pixels are filled with
other aerial shots and
other building photos
of the Smithsonian.
for a machine vision workshop
that might be somewhat interesting.
So the Smithsonian has 19 museums,
9 research centers, and a zoo
most of which are on the Smithsonian Mall,
but some of which are very far-flung.
We have the Smithsonian
Tropical Research Institute
in Panama, which has a large group of
very accomplished evolutionary
biologists, field biologists.
The Smithsonian
Environmental Research Center
out in Annapolis, Maryland, as well,
who do ecological research.
So, we're not just collections based,
but research data based as well.
When we talk about digitized collections,
I will keep a natural
history focus for now
just to to talk about the different
kinds of digitized data
that we're talking about.
Photos, so for example,
this is a photo of a pinned fly.
The taxonomic names, specimen records,
genomic sequences,
so we have data in GenBank,
geo-referenced localities,
and label data, transcribed
label data as well.
I would say that these are all
part of the collections object,
but then there are other kinds of
auxiliary data that might
be part of our understanding
of this one specimen.
Which could come from field books
where scientists who have
collected these specimens
wrote down some observations about it,
illustrations, again observations,
you know, what was this fly eating
at the time it was collected,
scientific publications,
and taxonomic descriptions.
These all could be linked,
these all are part of what
we know about this fly,
and being able to computer
cross all of these data
is something that we strive for.
This is just an example of
what a specimen collecting
event looks like
in terms of where the data go.
In the center this is Vicki Funk,
she's the curator of botany
and a great collaborator of mine.
So, for example, she
went out to collect this
purple very pretty flower,
the species is called
centrapalus pauciflorus.
We decided we wanted
to sequence this genome
because it is a part in
the sunflower family tree
that has no genome around it,
so we thought it would be interesting.
She collected the seeds, actually,
and we grew it in a greenhouse
because we needed a lot of DNA
for the kind of DNA
sequencing we were doing.
From the actual specimen,
most of the plant gets pressed,
and so you can see an
image of a pressed plant.
Some of it goes to a bio repository,
so we have its DNA forever.
You might sequence a small piece of DNA,
a barcode for plants, those
are chloroplast genes.
Those data go to NCBI,
which is part of NIH,
it's generally called GenBank.
The specimen information,
there's the specimen record,
which is in the Natural History Museum
it goes to a database called Emu,
and those data are pushed to GBIF,
the Global Biodiversity
Information Facility,
so that you can go to
GBIF and find records
of specimens from our museums
and also lots of other institutions.
The photo might go to iDigBio.
So, this is just one specimen,
and this all the places
that those data go to.
It gets way more complicated.
So, that's before any
research question, right?
So that's just like
we're going to document
that we collected this,
and have put it in the
places it needs to go,
but in order to do the research questions
Vicki's interested in,
we didn't wanna just sequence
the chloroplast gene.
We wanted to sequence the entire genome.
These are the different kind of parts
of research that we engage in.
The little museum icons at the top show
in order to generate
the deep learning models
that Alex will talk about later,
we need data from lots
of different museums.
We need specimen records,
locality information,
and images from all over the place.
In order to build a phylogeny,
we need to sequence, in this case,
this is a paper we're about to publish
with 256 species in the sunflower family,
we sequenced 1,000 genes
for all those 256 species.
So those data go to NCBI,
but we may, in some cases,
pull data from NCBI
from other institutions.
And then, for the genomics,
there's a huge amount of software tools
that we need just to assemble
and annotate the genome.
I'll show closer views of these.
We'll make a genome browser
that we can share with our collaborators
where they can continue to
keep editing our annotation.
Well, that's one genome.
What about all the genomes that are being
generated at the Smithsonian?
I'll show something that's
under construction for us,
which is the Smithsonian Genome Hub
where Smithsonian researchers can
put all their genomes in place,
and start thinking about
how to use them together.
So, the research is what adds
a huge amount of complexity.
Again, this is for one group of plants.
There are hundreds of
Smithsonian researchers
that are kind of doing
things along these lines.
I'll take a short little look at genomics.
Genomics at the Smithsonian has been,
we're generally really
good at natural history.
The scientists at the
Smithsonian know their organisms,
they know where to go in the
field to collect a species,
they know everything about it,
but genomics has been a big challenge
to get all the software
that researchers need
working well for their data.
This is just an example
of some of the tools
that you need to assemble
a genome and annotate it.
And a lot of times you
have to try multiple
kinds of software to see
what works best for the data.
This is just zooming
into the genome browser
that we're creating
where you have these prediction tracks.
So, this is just zoomed into
a very small piece of one scaffold,
and all of the gene predictions on there,
which scientists can go in and say,
"Okay, I know about genes
for drought tolerance."
I will go and look at those,
and see in detail does that look right,
and how can I extract that,
and compare it to other
genomes that I know about.
We're doing this in the cloud right now,
so we can easily share
it with other researchers
outside the Smithsonian.
So, we have a high-performance
computing cluster,
and part of my work is
helping to administer this.
There are about 4,000 CPUs
and 26 total terabytes of RAM.
That graph, the plot just shows
in the last 30 days the usage.
So, it is kind of up and down,
and it has a weekly cycle,
so people don't do as
much work on the weekends,
which is good.
But it's been really, really busy.
We have 16 very high memory nodes.
So, a genome assembly often you need
a terabyte or two terabytes of RAM
to assemble a genome.
These are pretty beefy nodes.
We have many high CPU nodes as well
because most of bioinformatic software
doesn't work well in NPI frameworks,
it's multi-threaded.
For GPUs, we have a node with NVIDIA K80s,
but more recently we've, my team,
has gotten two workstations
with NVIDIA GP100s,
and we'll probably upgrade
the GPUs in Hydra very soon.
We have more than 300
genomic software packages
installed on Hydra.
This is just an ongoing thing
where people are requesting things.
I don't know, maybe five times a week
we get requests for more software.
And around 550 users.
In terms of natural history,
that's about, I think, 182
natural history museum users of Hydra.
That's a lot.
Hydra started at the
Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory, astrophysicists are way ahead
in terms of of high-performance computing,
but we're catching up.
And so, we have as many biology users
as astrophysics user,
which is really a big change.
It's really exciting.
Training is a big part,
as well, of what we do
because we have hundreds of researchers,
curators, postdoctoral
fellows, graduate fellows,
interns that all wanna
do this kind of research.
So Smithsonian has joined
The Carpentries organization.
I'm sure many of you have heard of
data software and library carpentry.
We joined, I think, two years ago,
and now we have 13 trained instructors
with, I think, 10 more that are just
finalizing their instructor training.
In the past three years,
we've trained more than 300 researches
in Python, R, genome analysis.
We started doing more ad hoc workshops,
so people want to learn genome assembly,
so we would a six-week workshop
with an hour a week talking
about genome assembly,
but then we realized...
We did a survey of Hydra users,
and said, "What kind of
workshops are you interested in?"
and it turned out that Python, R
very ground level workshops and techniques
that they can then apply
to all sort of research
were what people were
really interested in.
We keep all our workshop
material on a GitHub page,
which you can go to.
As part of our website,
we have a schedule and place where you can
request workshops as well.
So, our instructors would be happy
to go anywhere and give these workshops.
Okay, and I'll talk a little about the
Biodiversity Genome Hub.
It's under construction,
but we're really excited about it.
So, the plan is to have a place
that's accessible not just
within the Smithsonian,
but to our collaborators
where we can have all of
our genome data together.
So, it's even hard for
us at the Smithsonian
to list all the genome
projects that are going on.
I've tried to get this information.
It's something like 150,
but having one place where we can bring
all the data together,
and have standards about how
people are storing that data,
and making sure it's backed up,
and making sure it's described in a way
that makes it reusable
is really important.
So, we're constructing this website,
which will be run through Galaxy,
which is a bioinformatics software.
An opensource way to make reproducible
pipelines and workflows
of different tools,
as it wraps around any kind of
bioinformatics tool you'd want.
And we hope to provide
researchers the ability
to do basic analytics on their
genomes once their sequenced
and share them with other people,
and hopefully allow students
and undergraduates and graduate students
to really get into genomics
in a not so intimidating way.
So, now I'll talk more about
the computer visions stuff.
Sorry for the detour,
but I think the genomics work
is still pretty exciting.
So, I'll give you four examples of
some of the work we're starting on.
The botany project is the most mature,
and Alex will be talking
about that this afternoon,
and the other ones are just
still experiments at this point,
but pretty exciting.
The Smithsonian
Digitization Program Office
has started a program in
the Natural History Museum
to digitize, or generate
images and transcriptions
of the labels for all
the botanical specimens
in the herbarium of which
there are five million.
So, there's this conveyor belt
that runs eight hours a day,
and generates thousands of images per day.
I don't know exactly.
I think there are three
million at this point
that are completed.
And as a first step, two
and half years ago or so,
we thought, "Okay, let's see if we can
"train deep learning models
"to classify, and to
detect mercury staining?"
Why mercury staining?
Well, botanists used
preserve their specimens
with mercury to keep pests away,
and we know now that's not
a great thing to have alongside people.
And you can see the specimen on the left
has been stained with mercury,
and over the years, the
mercury crystallizes out,
and so it's very visible to the human eye.
But it's not generally part of
the metadata for the specimen.
Sometimes there's a little
poison stamp on some of them.
We're not exactly sure if
that directly correlates
to whether it has mercury or not
or it could mean something else.
But we can see it, it's
not part of the metadata,
so we thought an interesting question was,
well, can the computers see it,
and can we then point out
hotspots in the collection
that might be, where some
mediation might be required.
They put the mercury stained specimens
that they know about into special folders,
but no one person can
open five million folders
to check the rest of them.
And then family ID.
These are two different
families of fern allies.
They're quite similar
to non-fern biologists,
such as myself (laughs),
and we thought we would do a very simple
binary classification problem.
Can we tell these apart
with good accuracy?
And NVIDIA helped us with
this first pilot as well.
So, these are just confusion matrices
showing for each model that we built
the number, this is just
the test set, so we...
I should have mentioned earlier
that we had to manually
find a training set
of mercury stained specimens.
So, it was a lot of hours
of going through images,
and we pulled, we had a set of 10,000
that were mercury stained
and 10,000 that were clean
that we labeled by hand.
And the confusion matrix shows,
just for a test set,
which of the stained and un-stained
actual images were predicted
to be stained and un-stained.
So, you would hope that
the diagonal going this way
would be 100%, it's not a 100%.
It did very well, so the
percentage is in the 90s
for both the family identification
and the mercury staining.
So, we're really excited about the fact
that this worked,
and you will hear what's next for botany
in a very, very, we've
expanded this greatly
this afternoon, so I won't
talk anymore about that.
We'll talk a little bit
about bumblebees as well.
You may say like, "That's pretty random.
"Plants and bumblebees," but (laughs)
because the Digitization Program Office
has targeted specific collections,
we've kind of gone with
where the data are right now,
and so the bumblebee project was to
photograph all the specimens
of bumblebees, around 45,000.
Bumblebees are all part
of the same genus, bombus.
And so, all of these were photographed.
This is just examples
of how the photos look.
They're generally just a lateral view.
Some of them are a dorsal view.
The labels are, as well, in the image,
and when I looked at the images I thought,
(laughs)
"I can't tell these apart at all.
"I don't know if this is going to work."
Entomologists might say,
"Well, you know, the
way we tell these apart
"is very specific banding
patterns and genitalia."
Well, we can't really
see that in these images
very well so I don't know,
but we'll give it a try.
The other interesting part of this project
is the transcription was crowdsourced
through the Smithsonian
Transcription Center,
which is where volunteers go online,
and can transcribe label data
which is a really great way to
get people involved in real research.
All of our labels, we have
good transcribed data.
So, we didn't really have to go through,
and make the training set ourselves.
The interesting thing is that
about more than 10,000 were unidentified,
and I talked to the bee
curator at Natural History,
and he said, "No, that can't be."
And then, we opened the cabinets and said,
"Yeah, 10,000 of these are unidentified."
So, the idea being that if our model
can classify to species pretty well,
we could at least have estimates
of what the other unidentified bees are.
We may not be able to put that
directly back into the collections system,
but we can at least tell
researchers coming in,
"You might also be
interested in these specimens
"because we think they're this species."
So, this didn't show up super well.
We trained two models so far.
A subgenus model, there
are 15 subgenre of bombus
that we have in our data set,
and the overall accuracy is above 93%.
And for the species model,
this was really interesting,
we're still just starting
out working with this,
but there's 178 species,
and some of them have 10 images or so.
And so, I've thrown them all in
even though those are very
small amounts of data.
It's still overall very accurate.
The next steps are to
talk to the bee curator
in more detail about whether
any of the things that
are more often confused
are actual taxonomic issues
that are either mislabeled in the data
or they are very, very closely related.
We're also just starting to experiment
with the activation heat maps
that we can generate from the models
that allow us to look at which pixels
are activated in the model,
and start understanding what the model
is looking at in the bee.
Success in this area
will be really important
to convincing the biologists that
it's not just a black box,
that we're actually...
the model is seeing the same
kinds of characters that you're looking at
on your microscope, and it's not so scary.
So, now I'll talk a little bit about
the project we're really just starting,
but the Smithsonian
Conservation Biology Institute
Center for Conservation
and Sustainability,
they work with oil companies mostly
to look at impacts of
installing pipelines,
mostly in the Amazon.
And, with this project, there is a company
that's looking to install
this flexible pipeline,
and they are looking to look
at baseline biodiversity
before, during, and
after the installation.
They've traditionally used camera traps,
and people actually catching
animals, taking DNA.
But we're trying a new approach
where fisherman have been given cameras
and given training into
how to photograph fish
that they catch.
We're getting the images,
and now we will start training a model
to see if we can identify fish to species.
And as the pipeline gets installed,
we can have a time series, hopefully,
of what the communities look like
before, during, and after
at different time points,
and then figure out what impacts
the pipeline has on fish communities.
That's really exciting
because it has real world impact.
And then, I'll talk briefly about
two other collaborations we're working on.
The United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum
approached us because they have lots
of digital data, mostly scans.
Although, the project we're talking about
is scans of documents without
any metadata about them,
just what archive they come from.
So, we are current looking for
a postdoc to lead this project to start
understanding more about the
kinds of documents that they have.
So, they have a lot of
diaries, letters, lists,
birth certificates, marriage certificates.
Just all sorts of archival
data around the time
that the Holocaust was happening,
and making it more
discoverable for researchers
that come to their museum to do research
and in terms of the digital
data don't know where to start.
So, we're hoping to make a dent in that.
And the Smithsonian American Women's
History Initiative is another
pan-Smithsonian initiative
that started last year
with a large digital component,
and we're hoping to contribute
by training machine learning models to
again, have a better baseline data
about how women have been involved in
the Smithsonian over time
both in collecting objects
as well as producing artworks.
You know, where are the
women in the Smithsonian?
What stories have we missed
in the last 150 years?
So, to that end, we have
some preliminary data
from Smithsonian archives
where we're looking at
official Smithsonian photographer images
where generally they go through
and identify people that,
let's say for example that
this is an example of a photo.
They're really just
interesting on a human level
to look at the photos of what
was going on in the 1970s.
In this case, the women
are all identified,
but there are many,
many thousands of images
where people aren't identified.
And in group portraits, more often,
men are identified and women are left out
for whatever reason.
So, we're hoping to first get a survey
of how many times women that are labeled
in these images show up in other images
that aren't labeled,
and to start getting some
baseline data about that.
Here are just some examples.
There are lots of group
portraits like these
where it's from a meeting
or from something else,
and people aren't labeled.
But maybe we can start making connections
between people where we have images
where we know where they are.
And also finding completely
outside of knowing who they are
clustering faces as well
in the official photographs
to try to find people who
maybe haven't been described.
We don't have their story represented
in any Smithsonian collection or metadata,
but maybe we can start
elevating their stories.
So, the takeaways are
we've really only just started this work.
There's so much to do.
And right now every, oh
sorry, there's a typo,
every application of machine learning
is a research project given our diverse
and incomplete, unique data.
So, I made another photo
mosaic of the castle
with all the portraits data
that I've got from archives,
so portraits of Smithsonian people
where we know the people.
I keep thinking who are we missing
when we're talking about who
has kind of built the Smithsonian,
and so, hoping that we can use these tools
to elevate new stories
that better represent
the people who actually
visit the Smithsonian.
And so here's my team,
and this work would not
happen without them.
We have from left my
postdoc Mirian Tsuchiya,
Mike Trizna, and Alex White.
Alex will be talking later.
Our partners across the Smithsonian,
again this work wouldn't be possible
without all the other Smithsonian units.
And funding, the Smithsonian
Women's Committee,
the Office of the Provost,
and the Office of the CIO.
Thanks.
(audience clapping)
(light music)